[Música]
el presidente de venezuela nicolás
maduro informó que su país acepta ser
garante del proceso de paz que el
gobierno de colombia adelanta con la
guerrilla de la ln esto pese a las
denuncias de que integrantes de este
grupo delincuencial se refugian en
venezuela caracas a fue garante en las
negociaciones con la ex guerrilla de las
farc llevadas a cabo en la habana
los restos de la reina isabel segunda
llevaron al palacio de buckingham
procedentes de edimburgo allí estarán
hasta que el féretro sea trasladado
westminster hall donde se llevará a cabo
la capilla ardiente de cuatro días
previamente el rey carlos tercero estuvo
en irlanda del norte donde se reunió con
unionistas y republicanos
el cineasta franco-suizo jean-luc godard
falleció a los 91 años el director fue
considerado uno de los padres de la
nueva ola francesa que revolucionó la
industria cinematográfica en su carrera
logró 51 galardones su muerte asistida
en suiza- reabre el debate en francia
sobre una práctica que aún es prohibida
allí tenemos análisis
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en venezuela
porque el presidente nicolás maduro
informó que su país acepta ser garante
en el proceso de paz que el gobierno de
colombia adelanta con la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional ln según
maduro el presidente colombiano gustavo
petro le hizo el ofrecimiento en una
carta
y le estoy diciendo al presidente
gustavo petro y a colombia que una vez
más como lo hizo el comandante chávez
en su tiempo para garantizar los
acuerdos de paz que luego se firmaron y
que me tocó participar como garantes una
vez más presidente gustavo petro y a
colombia le decimos venezuela acepta el
carácter de garantes de las
negociaciones y de los acuerdos de paz
de colombia con el ln y pondremos
nuestra mejor voluntad en nombre de dios
padre todopoderoso por la paz total de
colombia previamente conversamos con
daniela zambrano corresponsal de france
24 en caracas que nos dio más detalles
de la carta y la importancia de la
participación de venezuela en este
proceso en calidad de garante en la
carta se confirma que había una
conversación previa entre nicolás maduro
y su homólogo gustavo petro en el que se
habló además de retomar los protocolos
que ya se habían firmado y que se habían
acordado bajo el gobierno de juan manuel
santos en 2016 cuando se hablaba de un
acercamiento para conversaciones con él
ln que incluían estos protocolos que
volvieran la delegación de guerrilla a
colombia transitando por territorio
venezolano se dice que va a haber una
reunión pronta sin embargo no se habla
de fecha para ultimar los detalles de
cómo sería este encuentro en caracas
para posteriormente reanudar estos
diálogos con él ln venezuela es un
factor clave dada la fuerte presencia de
esta guerrilla en territorio venezolano
y aunque no es algo aceptado
públicamente por la administración de
nicolás maduro es bien sabido la
presencia que tienen en el territorio de
hecho una ong fundar redes y sus
directorios abierta razona lo han
denunciado en múltiples oportunidades él
fue detenido en julio del año 2021
acusado de supuesta incitación al odio y
terrorismo y él ha declarado que durante
la cuarentena y en los últimos años
sobre todo ha aumentado la presencia del
ln sobre todo en las poblaciones de
apure y táchira fronterizas con colombia
desde hace varias semanas los haitianos
se manifiesta en contra del gobierno por
el alto costo de vida y cuando se han
anunciado próximas alzas los precios de
los combustibles el martes se vieron
nuevos hechos de violencia en las
protestas con disparos de armas de fuego
que dejaron por lo menos un muerto en
puerto príncipe más detalles en el
informe de gabriel colchón
llantas quemadas bloqueando las rutas y
con nuevos disparos en la capital de
haití puerto príncipe las
manifestaciones no cesan este martes
ciudadanos se enfrentaron a la policía
lanzando piedras a las que las
autoridades contestarán con gases
lacrimógenos por lo menos una persona
falleció en las protestas el gobierno
del primer ministro a reloj está
nuevamente en el ojo del huracán tras
haber anunciado un aumento a los precios
de los combustibles
el pueblo está saliendo en masa
bloqueando el país y cerrándolo esto es
una señal para decir a ariel obi que
mientras siga al frente del gobierno el
pueblo no dejará de levantarse contra él
un anuncio que llega cuando ya la
inflación ha alcanzado su nivel más alto
en una década y cuando la violencia
entre las bandas ha dejado gran parte
del territorio fuera del alcance del
gobierno
los locales temen que las medidas
anunciadas obliguen a algunos negocios a
cerrar
y pequeños comerciantes conductores de
transporte público sea cual sea su rango
social hoy todo es disfuncional en el
país hoy este movimiento debe mantenerse
fuerte enviamos este mensaje al primer
ministro para que vea que esta condición
es invivible feedback las reservas de
combustible en haití se mantienen bajas
los importadores se topan con
dificultades para recibir los subsidios
del gobierno y para acceder a dólares
del banco central
el féretro de la reina isabel segunda
llegó al palacio de buckingham
procedente de edimburgo los restos de la
monarca aterrizaron a las afueras de
londres y luego fueron trasladados a lo
largo de 25 kilómetros en los que miles
de personas lo acompañaron y presentaron
ofrendas el féretro estará en la que fue
la residencia oficial de la soberana
durante sus 70 años de reinado hasta que
se ha transportado hasta el westminster
hall donde permanecerá en capilla
ardiente hasta el lunes cuando se
llevará a cabo el funeral del estado
manuel acá no tiene los detalles
[Música]
los ojos de miles de seguidores se
posaban sobre la catedral de saint
gilles en edimburgo después de que más
de 26 mil personas visitarán el cuerpo
de la reina isabel segunda salió hacia
su próximo destino londres
un coche fúnebre transportó el ataúd al
aeropuerto de edimburgo en compañía de
su hija la princesa anna las lágrimas y
la emoción acompañaron a los seguidores
de la monarca mientras veían el vehículo
alejarse triste pero encantador la
extrañaremos terriblemente creo que todo
el mundo lo hará
tengo la sensación de que era amada por
todos aquí no sabía la cantidad de amor
que las personas le tenían en escocia me
está afectando
en homenaje es el himno nacional y dos
minutos de silencio en marcaron el
despegue del avión con los restos de la
monarca más longeva de reunido el vuelo
de aproximadamente una hora terminó en
un aeropuerto en el oeste de londres
el aterrizaje fue presenciado por la
primera ministra de reino unido alistair
y el ministro de defensa ben wallace
entre otros en medio del silencio el
féretro fue trasladado a un coche
fúnebre encargado de llevar los restos
de la reina al palacio de bukingham la
residencia oficial de la monarca durante
sus 70 años en el trono
del aeropuerto al palacio el camino del
féretro estuvo acompañado por miles de
personas que se congregaron al lado y
lado de la carretera
una ovación recibió la tau de la reina
cuando entraba al palacio de buckingham
y desde allí el miércoles la fallecida
monarca será trasladada al westminster
hall donde permanecerá durante cuatro
días y en donde los londinenses y
visitantes podrán decirle adiós
jean-luc godard el cineasta franco-suizo
considerado uno de los padres de la
nueva ola francesa falleció a los 91
años por suicidio asistido en suiza
inició su carrera como crítico y luego
pasó a dirigir películas que
revolucionarían la industria de los años
60 una de sus obras más recordadas es a
wood su flor con el actor jean paul
belmondo
previamente mauricio durán profesor de
historia y teoría del cine nos explicó
cómo revolucionó salud boda el cine
francés
sí yo creo que fue todo un movimiento
también en conjunto con toda una
generación una generación que sufrió la
guerra e inmediatamente pues la
posguerra con triunfo de romer red otros
directores otros jóvenes que aún no eran
directores
asumieron la
[Música]
llevar a cabo acompañar la revista calle
del cine una una de las revistas más yo
creo que la revista más importante en la
historia del cine a partir de ahí se
forma y después
pues ya ya con la película que estabas
nombrando a que sufre
pues inicia toda una
tratamiento muy irreverente con las con
la tradición de un lenguaje del cine
clásico yo creo que colar y hay que
meterlo siempre dentro de este
movimiento y un movimiento aún más
grande no solamente francés sino de
muchos países
es quienes llevan a cabo el surgimiento
de un cine moderno versus un cine
clásico que amaron mucho porque yo creo
que es muy importante también decir que
jódar fue un grande se formó viendo cine
y amo absolutamente el cine clásico creo
que pocas personas conocieron el cine
como darth la historia del cine es todo
por el momento en france 24 les
agradecemos su sintonía volvemos en
breve con más información
[Música]